you  humanity's best weapon  master chief huh  the master chief was enhanced and  trained for one purpose  to win this war  he and the other spartans  are our only effective weapons against  the covenant  [Music]  here's lethal  upgradeable  and most importantly  controllable  covenant forces appear to be excavating  some kind of object  when i touched the object i felt  something  i felt  different  what they did to us  makes you known and you just decided to  help me why wouldn't spartan do that  what does one do with a superhuman  you're not sure you can trust  hello master chief  i'm cortana  master chief recovered something sacred  ring halo  [Applause]  humans  surrender to the covenant  cortana i'm gonna need you now  find the halo win the war  you